I've been running around with my kids all day,
but I did wanna come and drop some tags
and some handles of some accounts
that I think y'all should good check out.
I think you'll like them.
I'm gonna start with
the two that I'm the most familiar with.
These are mutuals of mine
that I've been following for years and years
and we've had many discussions
about some of these topics.
And that is Rosa Picosa and time and tenderness.
Cousin Tam is a homeschool
stay at home mom homemaker.
Deborah for Georgia
used to be mostly homemaking
and stay at home mom content.
She has now transferred to
a political candidate in Georgia.
So go Debra
and go follow her.
And then two just general like
mom accounts that I follow that I love are Philip A.
Jackson. Love her dearly.
Beautiful aesthetic,
mom content.
And Patrice Taylor.
She's the relatable
millennial mom that we all know and love.
And then if you want more of that, like,
1950s aesthetic,
my favorite account is actually on Instagram.
I don't think she has a TikTok,
but it's so Ranna all again.
Tag it down there.
Full 1950s kitchen,
1960s recipes,
full vibe. It's awesome.
I know I have more,
but that's a good start.